all right we've got something special
for you today instead of an interview
I'm going to play for you
one clip from the forthcoming heretofore
unseen pseudo-science miniseries okay
this is a miniseries that is going to
tackle 12 different pseudo-sciences we
will explain the pseudo-sciences to you
we will explain why they couldn't
possibly be real things as described and
it's going to be fantastic and today
we're starting with ESP extrasensory
perception we'll get to that momentarily
people have been waiting anxiously for
the next long-form thing that we would
be releasing and the reason it's been a
little while is because this is a 12
part miniseries each segment is going to
be pretty significantly longer than the
critical thinking miniseries and I think
people are going to like this Pat will
finally be disabused of his belief in
psychics as a result of this miniseries
which I know is something that could be
emotionally traumatic but I think for
the greater good yeah I used to believe
in all 12 of these pseudoscience they're
getting knock down one by one if I
wanted one at a time there will be
significant
disabuse of Pat's beliefs and this is
the work that we do because of the
support of people in the audience right
so when we say this vague amorphous hey
we're viewer and listener supported
media so on and so forth it's sometimes
hard to really give meaning to that but
what it actually means is we produce a
five day a week broadcast show for 200
radio and TV stations which we give away
to them at no cost because we consider
it to be a public service that is
literally funded by support from our
audience and likewise the pseudoscience
miniseries the critical thinking
miniseries it has all happened because
of support from the audience so if you
like what you are about to see
afterwards consider making even as small
as a $1 contribution through patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
are talking on today's program about
some of the challenges facing
independent progressive media in general
and if you want to support this type of
work and we have believe me we have no
shortage of ideas right we have actually
a very long list of ideas for long-form
pieces if you want to support not only
the regular show but the extra stuff
like what you're about to see become a
member
40% off with the coupon code vote soon
18 become a patron dollar-a-month
and if it's your last dollar don't give
it to us right I don't want your last
monthly dollar Pat he would accept it
but he doesn't want it okay well I'll
speak for him on in that sense but if
you have a dollar a month to contribute
to progressive independent media
consider doing that at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and I know that lots
of people in our audience do and with no
further delay because I think I've gone
on long enough
let's get to a preview of the
pseudo-science miniseries today starting
with the episode on extrasensory
perception our pseudoscience miniseries
now brings us to extrasensory perception
or ESP which is an umbrella term to
describe any kind of acquisition of
information through means other than the
established physical senses seeing
hearing smelling tasting and touching
someone claims to have ESP when they
tell us that they're able to sense
things outside their body through some
means other than these five senses so an
example would be
telepathy sensing another person's
thoughts clairvoyance sensing events in
another location precognition seeing the
future retro cognition seeing things in
the past that you didn't witness or
mediumship which would be communicating
with the dead or knowing things about
the spirits of dead people some people
call SP a sixth sense a psychic is
someone who claims to have one or more
types of ESP and we deal with psychics
in another episode of the mini-series
there's a 2016 report from Ibis world
which says that 85 thousand people in
the United States work as psychics
collectively earning about two billion
dollars a year and there's a 20-17
YouGov poll which says that a fifth of
Americans have consulted a psychic
in their life and that more than a third
of Americans have personally experienced
psychic ability in themselves at least
one time a quarter of Americans also say
that they can supernaturally predict the
future and 38 percent say that they have
sensed the presence of a spirit during
their life without these numbers you
might not realize how relevant this
pseudoscience miniseries is you might
see these videos on different
pseudo-sciences and think who cares only
wacky people believe this stuff but no
the numbers are stunning and many people
have no idea how pseudoscience pervades
our society so in a 2014 study in the
scientific journal PLoS ONE adults were
shown before and after photos of the
same woman for a second and a half
sometimes they were the same photo
sometimes something was changed about
the woman maybe the color of her hair
whether she was wearing glasses maybe
her earrings changed the people being
tested were asked if the pictures were
the same or different and if they
noticed the difference they were asked
what the difference was mostly people
could correctly identify when there was
a change and when there wasn't but
what's interesting about the results was
that people were able to detect the
change even when they weren't able to
cognitively and consciously identify and
express what the change was and when the
participants were informed of the
results the fact that they were able to
detect changes even without being able
to explain what they were some of the
participants believed that they had some
kind of ESP because they intuitively
knew that something about the photo had
changed but they couldn't quite put
their finger on it and they said well
the reason is some kind of extrasensory
perception one of the study's co-authors
said quote people are correct in
believing that they have an ability to
sense changes in their environment even
when they cannot verbally identify what
those changes are it is just that this
ability is not a quasi magical Sixth
Sense it can be explained in terms of
known processes and this is a major
theme in pseudoscience humans want to
explain what they don't understand
often by enemy
necessary you might not be conscious of
what you're perceiving so you might
interpret your correctness as something
supernatural there's a 2008 study at
Harvard which used brain scans to test
whether people claiming to have ESP were
actually acquiring knowledge that
couldn't be explained through some kind
of normal perception before the study
scientists already knew through
neuroscience that the brain responds a
certain way when it sees something
familiar and a different way when it
sees something new before the subjects
were brain scanned they were shown a
bunch of pictures by way of so-called
ESP what I mean by that is the
scientists would display the photos on a
computer screen in another another room
for example or they would show the
photos to the subjects relative or
partner or friend in a different room
they displayed it in a number of other
ways that someone with ESP might claim
could get them to sense the image
without actually seeing it then they put
them in an fMRI brain scanner and showed
them the same pictures mixed with new
pictures that hadn't yet been used not
only could the subjects not identify
which pictures were new with any
statistical significance but their
brains responded the same way to every
photo responding the way a brain would
respond if it had never seen any of the
photos these studies aren't the full
extent of all research into ESP claims
but it's a sample of how we can actually
test some of these claims all the time
people report unexplained knowledge
having a dream where something happens
and the next day it happens in real life
or you were thinking about someone and
the very next moment you get an email
from them a dream or a feeling coming
true can seem or feel too amazing to be
a coincidence but not when you think
about it like a statistician you spend
your entire life constantly thinking
feeling and dreaming and every once in a
while some of those thoughts and
feelings line up with actual events it
would actually be more amazing if it
never happened much of the time it's
your brain putting things together
without you realizing it many
psychological
go into what makes up our intuitions and
the subconscious inferences we make
every day we aren't fully conscious of
all the perceptions we have and were
rarely conscious of what our brain does
with the information
nothing has proven that anything beyond
our five senses along with our conscious
and subconscious minds are formulating
these intuitions and in fact to the
contrary there's a lot of evidence
showing that our normal senses are
actually what inform us when we think
that we're using ESP many people who
call themselves psychics or mediums or
clairvoyance probably do believe that
they have special abilities some of them
are also consciously fraudulently using
cold reading techniques to improve their
predictions analyzing someone based on
what you already know about them whether
it's their age their clothing their body
language or other characteristics
experiments and studies have failed many
times to prove the existence of ESP
which is a major issue
if you're trying to claim that it's real
but that doesn't prove it's not real
which is what gets us to another problem
with ESP and lots of pseudo-sciences
which is that they are unfalsifiable you
can't prove that ESP definitively does
not occur a skeptics this is when our BS
detector should go off right there's no
experiment or observation that could
disprove ESP so by definition the claim
that ESP is real cannot be a scientific
claim evaluated scientifically or
empirically it's effectively a claim
that is of no use to anyone in the real
world
who cares about evidence some who
believe in ESP might say claims about
ESP aren't supposed to be scientific
because it's by its nature supernatural
and therefore it's not even fair to
subject ESP to the type of empirical
scrutiny that one might want this would
be nonsense because ESP supposedly
interacts with the physical world we're
talking about having visions or
perceptions about what's happening in
material reality so it should be easy
to prove the accuracy of ESP if it were
actually accurate and at this point it's
unclear what kind of a conversation we
can even really have about that element
one of the biggest push backs against
ESP is common sense combined with what
we already know scientifically about the
natural world especially about vision
hearing neuroscience psychology physics
how could ESP possibly work it's a
difficult question for believers in ESP
to answer